all right well thanks very much
Vickie and thanks to Adam for inviting
me to give this webinar today as Vicki
said I'm an assistant professor at the
University of Washington in Seattle the
photo of meet in the mountains near
Seattle it's a wonderful place to live
unlike most of America we're not digging
out from a bunch of snow right now so
that's also very nice and I'm going to
talk today that cell death and of course
cells are live we know this and they
could die and in the sort of historical
classical way that we thought about cell
death had been at the dichotomy between
two different forms of death one is this
unprogrammed process of necrosis and the
other is the programmed and very well
described process of a pitocin when we
say program we mean a means for a cell
to die sort of on purpose a form of
cellular suicide that's carried out by
specific enzymes within the cell and
this is a figure from way back in 1995
so this is a sort of a theory they said
classical view of cell death necrosis is
the unordered killing themselves by a
chemical or environmental damage
so essentially you can think of it as
something like adding bleach to your
tissue culture dish would induce lots of
necroptosis freeze-thaw is another form
of necrosis toxins configuring the
closest on the other side of the Corning
we have acidosis and this is a program
process as I said this is a form of
cellular suicide that's carried out by
and really defined by the activation of
a space protease
so the caspases are apparently a
protease so protein cutting enzymes
they're cysteine proteases they cut
their substrates in aspartic acid and an
advertiser's is required for normal
development
mmunity and tumor suppression it's a
fundamental part of cell of normal
organism or function and of the sort of
cellular life cycle
several billion cells die in our bodies
by athetosis everyday acidosis is
defined by these distinct hallmarks and
these are again
the activation of these catfish
proteases when the past base has become
active in it cell that cell will shrink
its membrane will will blab and form
these sort of distinctive blistery
features the nucleus will condense and
when this happens in vivo these changes
lead to the expression of finding to be
an EEG signals on the dying cell the
dying cell is then rapidly recognized by
a spag acidic white blood cell this is a
depicted here in in this sort of
artist's rendition of a phagocyte
recognizing an appetite excel and and
for this reason because of this this
sort of distinctive program associated
with appetizers we generally think of
apoptotic cell that is tidy and non
inflammatory way to eliminate cells from
the orbit so this again happens many
billions of times in our bodies every
day and that doesn't really cause much
of an inflammatory or immune response so
you know I mentioned this sort of
dichotomy between half a ptosis and you
didn't cross it remember this is
classical unprogrammed necrosis as a
sort of historical or classical way of
thinking about this because we now
understand that there are other ways for
a cell to die in a programmed manner
there are other cell death program two
of those that are that are that are
receiving a lot of attention now our
pyroptosis this is mediated by different
members of the caspase family and in in
response to a certain immune stimuli
mainly in macrophages and then the other
form of program spelled that necroptosis
which is going to be the focus of much
of my talk today and you know again just
to sort of from from a broad overview
perspective we generally sort of think
of a pitocin as a non inflammatory
silent form of death and we think of
these other forms of death as
potentially inflammatory or at the very
least sort of crisis forms of death that
will mainly seem to occur in response to
infection or stress in when when when a
tissue needs to sort of greeny alarm
bells so
I'm gonna talk first a little bit about
the extrinsic pathway of apoptosis and
then how some of the same signals
involved in a photonic signaling can
also trigger this other form of death
network services that I've just that
I've just introduced so extrinsic
epitope this is so named because it's
the activation of the isotopic pathway
by signals that come from outside of a
cell notable among these is activation
of the death receptors fast for the
receptor and TNF receptor on the cell
surface by the cognate ligands when
these receptors are activated in in
various ways they can then activate
recruit and activate an initiator
caspases caspase-8 and i'll talk a lot
more about activate in the later part of
the presentation but in this apatite
pathway caspase-8 activation can then go
on to activate members of the bcl-2
protein family these proteins have the
job of determining whether to and then
eventually going ahead with the
permeabilization of the outer
mitochondrial membrane criminals
permeabilization of this membrane allows
the release of proteins that are
normally sequestered inside that
membrane among these is cytochrome c
cytochrome c then binds you to an
adapter a path one and activates a
full-blown castex cascade leading as i
said to a photonic cell death and we can
we can just show you some cells dying by
Apatow psious user HeLa cells expressing
systems GFP to mark their nuclei and and
they've been triggered to undergo
apoptosis by a combination of TNF and
cycloheximide this is a very sort of
classical a static sim and you can see
here the cells strength and they blab
they have this sort of very typical
blistering morphology and and then much
later they undergo what we call
secondary necrosis where they're there
their membranes actually lose integrity
but as I said normally in vivo we would
expect that these dying cells would be
recognized in fact Saito's taken up by
by a phagocyte
long before they lose membrane integrity
so these cells would be rapidly
eliminated then this would be a sort of
non inflammatory process
so of course and the process of studying
all of these pathways many knockouts
have been made of different members in
that way and you know if we think of as
I've introduced adapt a ptosis as a way
to eliminate cells from the body you'd
expect that knocking out throw a
photonic enzymes or proteins would lead
to phenotypes associated with too many
cells right you get rid of a photonic
the a photonic program and you end up
with too many cells and usually this is
the case so if you knock out for example
fast which is one of the receptors
responsible for the exit of apoptosis
the media type you get is excess immune
cells and autoimmunity if you knock out
some of the pro apoptotic bcl-2 family
you get again autoimmunity in some cases
mice that are more prone to two murders
again associated with an overabundance
of cells in certain cases very
interesting that you get mice with
webbed feet this is because the inter
digital space in in mice as in humans is
sculpted by a pitocin and so if you
eliminate some of these be stale food
family members you actually can't can't
sculpt the digits correctly and you end
up with partially webbed feet if you
knock out some of these downstream
executioner's like nine and eight baths
you get mice that have actions
definitely that have actually have a
brain that extends outside their skull
because they have an overabundance of
neurons the skull can't close around the
brain and this obviously is embryonic
lethal to these mice so in all these
cases knockout of pro apoptotic genes
and proteins leads to too many cells as
you would expect but there is an
interesting exception to this rule and
that's caspase-8 so remember taxpayers
ages this executioner there's this
initiators back page that's activated by
the death receptors and if you knock out
castes eighty unexpectedly you get
embryonic lethality it around
developmental day eleven and this seems
to be due to a thematic validity that
and indeed the conditional loss of
caspase-8 in lymphocytes so if you
delete calf is eight and lymphocytes
only using lockscreen technology you end
up with t-cells that can't proliferate
normally in response to antigens so
again this
appears to be a growth reported defect
that is manifested by the knockout of
castes aid so that's sort of interesting
and slightly unexpected and it led us to
let me remind my my postdoctoral work
your sort of address try to address this
question calculates eight uniquely among
these a photonic proteins seems to be
required for normal development and
lymphocyte activation why is this the
case and we now understand why this is
the case and the leaders that cast
potatoes required for for these these
these events is that it's caspase-8 is
also involved in the suppression of a
different form of cell death necroptosis
which i've already I've already
mentioned also sometimes called program
to closes so the way that program
necrosis or or necroptosis I'm going to
use those terms interchangeably the way
that this form of cell death is
initiated is again in response to some
of these stainless factors but it's
activated by a family of kinase the
ripped kinase rip
excuse me kinase is the sets that are
interacting protein kinase and the way
that is this this sort of generally
works is that activation of BDNF
receptor leads to the recruitment of rip
1 rip 1 participates in NF kappa-b
signaling downstream of the TNF receptor
and this is sort of the normal function
of the TNF receptors to activate in a
kappa b and a promote inflammatory and
inflammatory cytokine response but rip
one can then translate eight out of this
TNF receptor complex to form a second
complex in the cytosol and in that
second complex rip one can interact with
another member of the family rip free
and this interaction leads to the
recruitment and phosphorylation of a
pseudo kinase called ml KL which then
translates to the cell membrane
permeable eise's the cell membrane and
leads to cell death and this whole
process is suppressed by cascade and so
so in the absence of template when you
knock out a phase eight you get
unchecked TNS mediated a rip one and
three dependent cell that
leads to the organismal death in the
cases do not have much so I just want to
show you a picture of some cells
undergoing necroptosis to give you a
sense of what they look like and how
this form of death is distinct from a
purchase
here are some against some HeLa cells
that have now been stimulated with TNF
in combination with the café's inhibitor
remember you need you need to inhibit
the caspases to unmask this necro
product cell that the spot and you'll
see that they're gonna die in a very
different way to those apathetic cells
they're going to swell and then actually
pop like little balloons pop so you can
see it it's very clear and very distinct
morphology associated with rip 1 and
root 3 activation and how different it
is from Apatow sious so here's a little
sort of schematic of how we think of
these things these pathways working
activation of the receptor can activate
caspase-8 which can lead to a pitocin
and the same the same cafes cafes ate
can also suppress this other form of
death which can also be activated by the
same receptor by by blocking rippln
reactivation when Casper's data is
absent rip 1 and rip 3 lead to this
program the chronic cell death so this
is to be demonstrated very clearly by
the fact that the embryonic lethality of
the candidate knockout mice is fully
rescued by about a knocking out rip 3 so
the café's a double knockout mice are
born normally and they and they survive
and are mostly okay so for and
furthermore as I already alluded to
combining TNS receptor stimulation so
activating this receptor and the
presence of a café's inhibitor such as
zeebad
so blocking the cat phases will lead to
the activation of rippln and rips 3
mediated necroptosis and so this is sort
of become a classical way to trigger
necroptosis in cells
TNF in combination with me VAD will very
nicely block a pitocin and instead
sensitize themself an echo taught excel
death which depends on on rip 1 rip
so here's the sort of a slightly broader
view of the neck of tonic pathway I told
you about how the death receptors TNF
receptor and back ten can activate
necroptosis by via rip one kill our
stimulation is regular tlr3 and tlr4
which can activate the adaptor molecule
trip can also trigger necroptosis and
very interesting Leone viral infection
it can also directly activate this form
of death in the case of DNA viruses this
appears to go through the DNA sensor Dai
in others in the case of other types of
viral infection it's not totally clear
how this pathway is engaged but
interestingly rip three knockout mice so
mice that don't have the neck robotic
pathway are very sensitive to a number
of different types of viral infections
so it's likely that that in fact the
engagement of this pathway by viruses is
one of the key sort of physiological
functions of mecca Joseph but I just
want to show this to note that that
while I'm gonna be talking a lot about
TNF induced necroptosis there are many
other types of stimuli they can trigger
this form of death um as I've already
told you TNF and also and in these
others as well can also activate NF
kappa-b dependent transcriptional
responses and of course that a TLR
stimulation as well as a viral infection
can also lead to need these types of
transcriptional cytokine responses
furthermore I've already mentioned a
pitocin and have caspase-8 can
contribute athetosis and of course all
of these stimuli in certain conditions
can also trigger apoptosis right they're
not these aren't unique neck robotic
stimuli depending on the engagement or
in addition of the caspases these same
stimuli can also in some cases trigger a
psychotic death and furthermore as I as
I already mentioned the cash basis can
suppress necroptosis so this gets very
complicated in a hurry there there are
all these different different stimuli
and depending on what's president of
cell cytokine responses necroptosis or
appetizers can be engaged so we were
really interested in studying
this complex directly with Rick won and
rip three and how rip one activates rip
three to regulate the engagement of
necroptosis so we of course ask the
question how can we isolate and study
these proteins without all of this very
complicated other signaling habit and so
we turn into a strategy that's been used
for the study of the acidotic pathways
which is inducible dimerization so the
way that this works in a case of the cat
phases is that you simply excuse this
inducible dimerization domain shown here
in orange on to your castes of interest
so you make a chimeric protein that you
can then Express in yourselves and then
you add this dime Preiser
a small molecule - it's a raffle - to
these these cells and you induce that
that will fix acute conversation domains
together induce the dimerization of your
castes and lead to its activation and a
somatic death so we wondered what might
happen if we took a similar approach to
the activation of RIP 3 what if we use
in dimerize about 3 could we could we
induce cell death and might we be able
to uncouple the activation of RIP 3 from
these very complicated upstream of
stream effects so we undertook a very
straightforward experimental strategy we
created a fusion protein of risk 3
composed of rip 3 fused to one of these
SV domains these inducible dimerization
domain and we express this protein in 3
T 3 NIH cells which lack endogenous rip
breed then we added our done [ __ ]
dimerize ER which we're calling a t1 and
the state to the cells and we simply ask
the question do they die and very
importantly um I I want to point out
that the rip wanted root 3 these kinase
is the trigger necroptosis normally
interact via this domain called the rim
domain and this is a small domain and
the street terminus of gripp3r if one
also contains a rim domain and these
Grendel names have already has
previously been described to form these
only the Marek fry on like structures
upon activation so these REM domains are
sticky little domains that can they can
stick many of them of them together into
these larger fry on like structures that
seem to be associated with the
activation of rip 1 and rip rate so and
this will be important because we're
going to be we're going to be mutating
the rim domains and some of these
constructs so I just want to point out
what the rim that mean does and to study
this we we made use of a very handy
piece of equipment that we have in the
lab called the inca site imager and the
inca site is essentially an imaging
platform that sits inside a tissue
culture incubator and allows us to image
and quantify cells over time and get
these very nice cell that curve and so
this allows really great kinetics
precision of how many cells are dying
over time and so what we have here is
simply some simply expressing cells
treated with either TNF alone which
normally doesn't trigger a tremendous
amount of cell death it's normally an
inflammatory cytokine or alternatively
treated with TNF in combination with the
cascade inhibitors ebed and remember
that when you inhibit a cash basis in
combination with TNF you sensitize cells
to connect aprotic cell death and so you
can see this is just a time course of
these cells dying and when they die they
take up a double and permeable nuclear
die that we put in the media and they
fluoresce very brightly green when they
lose membrane integrity and the incus I
can count these cells as they die those
just played on a loop the King County
cells as they die and so it's varying
with a very nice half-hour intervals
here we're quantifying how many cells
are dying in this population so we can
give these very nice curves I'm going to
be showing lots more of these kinds of
cell death terms throughout the talk and
I just want you to understand how they
were generated so we had went ahead with
our experimental strategy which I've
already mentioned we took our rip three
protein used to a dimerization domain we
express this in cells that don't have
any endogenous rip free and we added Don
riser and we
we did in fact and get some cell death
and this was we we were able to confirm
through a number of different ways this
was dependent on the kinase activity of
grip 3 the downstream effects REM lkl
and so on
and we got somewhat limited effects
about 30 to 40 percent cell death when
we added our diver Iser but you know
this told us that we could seemingly
activate with a free via dimerization
now something that we were a little bit
surprised by was that when we mutated
the rim domain of RIP 3 so we inserts
put a small tetra alanine mutation into
the key the key activation point of
Delinda main we now completely abrogated
our ability to activate this constructs
by dimerization so now remember that
this is you know we're activating by
addition of our small molecule drug and
dimerization of this sv domain so this
was a little bit surprising to us we
didn't expect that that that form of
activation would require the REM domain
of over 3 so as i mentioned already the
rim domain has been described to form
all the generic structures when R is
activated and we were able to resolve
only for murders induced by dimerization
of these constructs via DSS
cross-linking so this is we essentially
took cells activated root 3 in them
broke them open added this cross-linking
reagent to man ran them out on a Western
blot and we were able to track very
nicely these ripped free monomers the
formation of dimers and in the context
of the bleeding one x sv the version of
this that has an intact Rim domain we
got this very nice formation of oligo
MERS when we used the version that last
the rim domain no legalization was
observed so we got a nice dimer but no
bill only reversed and so what we think
is happening here is simply this when we
dimerize rip 3 we we stick two molecules
together but in the absence of that RIM
domain there's no further effects than
the simple dimerization of RIP 3 doesn't
lead to cell death on the other hand
when we dine rise rip 3 with an intact
rim domain we're then able to recruit
additional molecules of grip
via these rim rim interactions and build
these nice rip three oligomers which
seemed to me required that so
legalization seems to be required for
the the activation of necroptosis so
that was that was very nice and you know
that made some sense so we thought that
we would see what would happen if we we
added some of the inhibitors that we
normally use to modulate TNF induce
necroptosis so remember TNF alone
doesn't really trigger cell death unless
you combine that that would leave at and
you can just see that here TNF treatment
alone no data you had Nevada cafes
inhibitor and now you unmask this this
neck photonic pathway to our surprise
however when we dine rich green right so
when we form these oligomers using the
dimerization system that I just outlined
in this case as I said we get limited
cell death but it's the Ann Zieve add to
these cells we now greatly potentiate
the cell death response and so remember
there's no TNF involved here this is not
a receptor mediated activation of
Brittany its activation of rip street
directly in the cytosol using our small
molecule and also it's somewhat
confusing to us when we did the same
thing dimerize ripped three in the
president necro statin which is inhibit
rip one the upstream activator of rip
three we reduce the amount of cell that
we see upon rip three dimerization and
we were able to demonstrate disease
effects are entirely independent of TNF
or a receptor engagement so so you know
what this seems to indicate is that the
rip one is actually able rip one and
cafés eight I should say are actually
directly modulating the activation of in
the cytosol independent of TNF or or
receptor engaged and as I've mentioned
already the rim domain is required for
the interaction not only between
different molecules of rip 3 but also
between rip 1 and rip free and so we
were able to show that when you dimerize
rip 3 in the cytosol so when you
directly activate rip 3 you recruit with
one and caspase-8 so the
an IT experiment when we see very nice
recruitment of grip 1 and cafes 8 and
indeed this is potentiated by XIV ad so
when we add XIV add to these to these
these constructs we get more recruitment
of Brooklyn and cafes and we can see
this again in the context of
oligomerization here when we when we
look in the formation of these oolagah
murders dimerization alone gives us some
some modest organization when we add
necro Staten the inhibitor one that
oligomerization guys produced and when
we add vivre add the cafes 8 inhibitor
that oligomerization is potentiated so
this matches very nicely the cell death
responses that we saw in the last slide
so so you know that led us again to
think that perhaps rip 3 is directly
modulated by a caffeinated rif-1 in the
cytosol independent of this receptor see
and so remember that you know one of the
things that I just showed you is that
the RIP 1 inhibitor necro Staten blocks
rip 3 dependent cell deaths so you know
we thought that this muscle beating that
rip 1 is promoting rip 3 activation
right you inhibit rip 1 you get less rip
reactivation cytosol therefore rip one
is promoting relaxation but what we saw
was something a little bit different so
we we wanted to of course make sure that
necro Staten wasn't having an off target
effect and so we did an experiment where
we knocked down rip 1 using SI RNA it'll
be found in fact was that the inhibition
of RIP 1 by nekross staten and the
knockdown of rip 1 using an SI RNA
actually had opposite effects and that
in the inhibition of necklace statin of
a Rick won by an extra statin reduced
cells s responses while knock down a rip
1 greatly potentiated them and again
remember this is independent of any
receptor signaling this is just directly
activating rip 3 in the cytosol
so this told us that the presence of rip
1 is not required for its reorganization
activation and we hypothesized that
perhaps necklace statin 1 actually asked
by turning rip 1 into a dominant
negative inhibitor of oligomerization
right so in fact here the inhibition
senior is not because rip one is
required for reactivation but rather
because nekross statin inhibited rip one
is blocking that that phenomenon and so
you know this is a little schematic of
how we think that might look with three
dimerization we think to the crew trip
one and once one is recruited one can
perhaps mediate this depression of
further rift three oligomerization by
recruiting cafes eight and flip these
suppressives suppresses members of the
neck razón so this this led us to
hypothesize you know we wondered we
thought this was very interesting rip
one is not only an activator of risk
free but it can also have this
inhibitory role and so we wondered you
know where this might be important
physiologically and we hypothesized that
in the absence of rip one and caspase-8
mediated suppression when three might
undergo spontaneous oligomerization in
the cytosol
that is to say while rip one can
activate rip three in some conditions
our findings implicated rip ones as a
potential inhibitor of rip three
independent of receptor signaling just
in the cytosol and so the test is we
turn to a different system shield
dependent destabilization domain and so
this is a small molecule
I'm started a small a protein domain
that you can fused onto a protein of
interest it's rip free and this will
lead to the rapid proteasome dependent
degradation of that protein under normal
conditions when you add a small molecule
ligand of this domain it will now
stabilize the protein fuse to the domain
so you can see here these are cells
expressing our destabilized form of RIP
three when we add our shield drug into
these cells rift 3 accumulates over time
and we wanted to use this system to test
whether the absence of rip one with
three accumulation without any
additional activation without any TNF
stimulation or anything of that nature
simple accumulation of ripped lead might
be enough to kill a cell if it
than have written one present so we
first just did some knockdowns looking
at CNF induced cell death and we saw as
we expected that when we when we
activate with TNF and knock down castes
eight we get this great necro tonic
response knock down rip one doesn't
really have any effect on TNF induce
cell death because rip one is downstream
TNS and we didn't expect it to be
required for a lot of the the TNF
mediated function but interestingly when
we now accumulate with three over time
so we now add our shield drug and a
tally and just increase the amount of
risk read and sell some know TNS
stimulation yet just rip three
accumulating the cytosol we now get this
very potent cell that responds when we
knock down pathways eight but also when
we knock down rip one so not lots of
either rip one or cascade eight now
leads to the spontaneous receptor
independent activation of a rip three in
the cytosol so we this was interesting
to us and it implies that rip one can
actually block rip free activation
independent of receptors but we wanted
to understand better how this might
happen how this this inhibitory function
of rip one might be might be working so
we hypothesized that rip one like co-op
away with castes age to prevent the
formation and propagation of rip three
Oleg immerse so remember that that I
already told you that rip three Oleg of
arises in when it's activated and we
hypothesized that maybe rip one can
actually sort of interplay any of those
older murders recruit tasks a disease
and prevent their formation
so we reason that if this is the case
enforcing rip three Oleg memorization
rather than simply diamond rising rip
three and allowing it to oligomers via
rim rim interactions should remove rip
three from the control of rip one and
cafes eight so if we stick enough risk
three together we should now abrogate
the ability of rip one and cafes a to
suppress rips react and so to do that we
created these forms of rip three that
have to do dimerization domain bomb
so rather than a single domain which
will simply dimerize rip three and allow
risky complexes to grow by a rim
interactions we now put a second FV
domain on to rip three which will now
allow cross-linking of the RIP three
protein in the formation of large large
rip through all the numbers independent
of the root domain and we found very
nicely that when we use these as needing
double dimerization domain we greatly
potentiated to cell death response so
remember before with the simple
binarization of drift three we were
seeing about 30% of cell death now we
get nearly 100% cell death so when we
Oleg arrives rip to me directly and
furthermore very very interesting Lee we
find that this Oblinger ization is wim
independent so if we use a form of
referee that completely last the rim
domain which as you recall when
dimerized is that does that form of rip
doesn't have any effect as we sports rip
three in the oligo murders now we get
this very potent cell death response
this completely grim domain independent
right so this photochemically of course
the oligomerization can substitute for
those rim rim interactions by adding a
second death me domain now we discourse
rip three in the oldest independent of
the rim and furthermore organization is
both necessary and sufficient for rip
reactivation so this really sort of
demonstrates very nicely that in fact
you need to get all of the rotation who
are cell death because remember the
single at me version of this constructs
didn't kill at all and we can we can you
know probe this with with western wats
techniques again this is cross-linking
old humors and we denied all of the
reformation both with or without the rim
domain when we went in this to xfb
constructs the the version with the rim
domain interaction with rip one beta
version without the remedy did not but
consistent with our hypothesis we find
that the drug enforce over legalization
of rip three completely removes rip
three from the control of either
cats these days or rip one so now we add
xiv add or necro status which remember
modulates the activation of rip three
oligomers when we when we add these
these drugs who are our
are to xsv versions are in elimination
versions of rippity we now see
absolutely no effect so basically what
do you for a pretty rollin over rip 1
and cafes they are no longer able to
exert any kind of control over over the
river de Oleg amore which is consistent
with the idea that they're acting that
the rip 1 & Cafe they acted the level of
really memorization to control rip
reactivation so how do we think that
this actually works physiologically let
me sort of step back and just give you a
little bit of a model rook 1 as I
introduced it is upstream of RIP 3 so
during normal receptor mediated
activation of gripp3r if one is
phosphorylated and activated I'm sorry
it's a it's generated and activated and
there's a complex series of molecular
modifications to rip 1 rip 1 can then
recruit rip 3 and phosphorylated and
this appears to potentiate the
oligomerization of rip 3 recruitment of
ml KL and the induction of programmed
necrosis
so during receptor-mediated necroptosis
rip 1 is activated rip 3 is activated
MLK is activated and you get cell that
since the way we think of this is a
relatively linear pathway but remember
those written domains are sticky they're
their oligomers egg fry on like little
domains and so we hypothesized that in
the cytosol of a healthy cells which 3
can probably sort of run into other
molecules with some regularity and when
this happens these Lin domains can
canola memorize and and lead to risky
phosphorylation when this happens
in the absence of rip 1 or caspase-8 you
would obviously expect to get tell that
so to prevent that we we hypothesized
that one is recruited to these
spontaneously formed rip 3 all gamers
recruits cafes 8 and flip and actually
suppresses the formation of of
necroptosis inducing really reverse via
probably by the degradation of these
complexes mediated by the CIA PS
although exactly how that works
is not is not totally clearance so in
this in this model with sort of
interesting to keep in mind is that with
once in act in some cases as an
activator of risk free but importantly
in other cases in its steady state rip
one is actually suppressing rip
reactivation and if you're interested in
this in this idea and if you want to see
something really very elegant genetic
models that are consistent with this
idea that it has been have also been
published recently you can you can now
just steer you toward this very nice
recent review by Ricardo weinlick and
Doug greens published in Molecular Cell
recently these are former colleagues of
mine and and they know what they're
talking about so so take a look at that
if you're interested in learning more
about this whole this whole idea so with
that I would just like to close by
thanking the people who did the work and
in particular Susanna Orozco a fantastic
graduate student in my lab here at the
University of Washington I also want to
acknowledge my collaborators and in
particular the Deir Yassin and Matthew
Albert there is a graduate student in
that halpert's lab at the institut
pasteur in paris they have been very
close collaborators throughout this
process he were broadsky to the
University of Pennsylvania symbolic
Condren at Fox Chase Cancer Center and
Steve stated the Beaton Institute in the
UK and and with that I will turn the
microphone over to Miriam from a scam
who's going to talk a little bit about
some of the ads and products that they
have available to study some of these
pathways thank you Andrew for such an
interesting and comprehensive
presentation and I would like to take
this opportunity to talk to you about
some obscure products that might be of
interest for you I would like to make
you aware of the range of lab map
antibody products for necroptosis
markers few of the markets available at
the moment
include ribs caspase-8 m and M LK o
Rabab antibodies are worried monoclonal
antibodies with high affinity and high
specificity and have been extensively
validated in multiple relevant
applications such as Western blot and
IHC
as well as in several species our
scientists are currently working on
bringing to you soon all the rap maps
products against whip 3 and his first
spoken to thunder and also a specific
Mouse MLK our antibody I would like to
highlight our roadmap antibody against
phosphorylated ml tail sweet Emma kale
on first on seven three five eight this
is a highly specific antibody against
the human protein and it's ideal for
Western blot NIAC experiments on the
publication highlighted on the right in
molecular cell last year won it all
describe how the antibody was developed
and how they study the specificity of
the antibody if you are looking for
general cell death markers that can be
used to detect both apoptosis and
necroptosis we have a range of kids that
might be useful for you if you want to
detect caspase-8 activation we have a
range of products available you can
detect activation by flow or fluorescent
microscopy using a fitzy over them in
staining also a simple microplate
reading experiment using colorimetric
after emetic detection if you want to
easily differentiate between life and
death cells our simple are safe for life
and death cells can give you the answer
in just 10 minutes you can visualize the
sales by flow cytometry or in a
fluorescent microscope other products
for assessing cell death that you might
find useful
our assays to detect changes in the
mitochondrial membrane potential there
are several dyes you can use in such EMR
a GC a 1o d c---ten all these dyes are
very easy to use and quick to visualize
the image on the slide shows the
staining of mitochondria with p.m. RI
which can be used in both adherent and
suspension cells when studying cellular
pathways it is essential to use the
right tools so we have a range of
inhibitors and activators of makeup
closest pathways that you can use to
ensure that you are looking at the right
cellular activity
and if you have seen from Angie's
presentation there are several
necroptosis markers which are apoptosis
markers as well if you are interest in a
quick and simultaneous detection of
several of these markers why not using
an antibody array to quickly check
whether caspase-8 fast or TNF alpha have
been activated in your samples you can
detect up to forty three markets at the
same time in four to eight cell or
tissues life sites so thank you for your
attention
and without further delay I will press
the microphone back to Andrew who is
ready to answer your questions
alright well thanks very much we've had
several questions come in and I think I
can I think I can get to the answers one
of the first questions and I think this
is a great one is does necroptosis cause
inflammation in vivo and it's it's a
great question and you know we as I
presented necroptosis and compared it to
appetizers I said that necroptosis is
planetory for cell death um the problem
is that you know it hasn't really been
easy to demonstrate that so there aren't
yet and we're starting to develop them
but there aren't great tools to really
detect necroptosis in vivo so you know
the only one of the only tools that
we've had us now has been with knockout
mice you can take a rip knockout Mouse
and you can give it as the same stimulus
that you give a wild-type mouse and see
whether it has a different response
right see whether the inflammatory
response is reduced when you eliminate
the necro tonic pathway that seems to be
the cases some with some stimuli so for
example TNF induced sterile septic shock
if you just inject a bunch of TNF into a
mouse it will get very sick and it's
it's body temperature will drop and
it'll eventually die and that response
seems to be partially abrogated in rip
through knockout so that's the condition
where it seems that some part of that
inflammatory response does depend on
Ribery now you know the challenge there
is to discern whether all of that with
that effect is due to network
sell that as opposed to potentially some
other functions in rip three that maybe
we don't understand yet could really
have itself have a transcriptional role
for example so you know just just now
with some of the the reagents that
Miriam has described we're now starting
to be able to directly look for networks
on excels in things like tissue sections
so using for example that fossil ml tail
antibody so it's a good question but not
one that I think that we really firmly
know the answer to yet despite many
reviews that present necroptosis
inflammatory let's see another just a
sort of central question what kind of
dye was used to detect neck robotic
cells that's a guy called site tox green
it's a cell impermeable DNA dye and very
important you want sites hoc with an X
to the N X Y tio X there's another
version of that same guy that cell
permeable that bulb site Joe green s yto
and that's the best dye that we found
for these types of assays incredibly
bright it really lights up cells once
they die let's see another question here
is my micro micro array results show up
regulation of rip 3 and ml kale can I
assume that the pathway of cell that is
by programmed necrosis or do I need
other genes for verification that's a
good question I don't think that you can
assume that both rip 3 and M lko are
interferon response so the interferon
stimulation will up regulate rip 3 and M
okay l but it won't necessarily trigger
necroptosis in certain conditions
interferon signalling pin trigger or at
least sensitized cells to necroptosis
how exactly that works again is not not
totally understood but but I think that
it's that up regulation of the genes is
not enough to determine that it cell is
undergoing neckla kosis you need to
obviously determine whether your cells
dying and if your cell is dying then
something like a faso ml KL reagent or
using a knockout for rift 3 or ml KL
would be the best way to really
determine that necroptosis is at play
and in those cells a question here I
only recently discovered the existence
of necroptosis so it's what you to me
and I wonder what are the possibilities
of detecting it in a paraffin tissue
sections right now really the only the
only option is the possible ml KL
antibody that that that Miriam talks
about you know that's sort of that's as
good as we have right now hopefully in
the near future a scam will be able to
give us something like a possible risk 3
antibody that'll work really well and
pair of conditions that as far as I know
the fossil ml KL is really the best
verified me agent at this point notably
it only really works in in human human
tissue sections so that's that's a
challenge but you know again with with
the the diligent work from the folks at
Afghan I'm hopefully more reagents to
study these pathways will become
available
let's see another question here what is
your opinion of of necroptosis oh hang
on sorry do the next doesn't happen in
brains and neurons I don't really know
the answer that question the brains and
neurons did not seem to express very
much rip 3 at least at steady-state but
whether you know whether whether in
disease conditions that and passed with
the pathway might be engaged I don't
really know let's see another question
here 10 necroptosis be induced
independent of rip kinase activation I
think that I would say that the answer
is no but it's but it depends on you to
find necroptosis I suppose I mean you
know the necrosis it was sort of
initially described in this new study in
the context of the rift kinase is sort
of the defining characteristic of mecha
products cell death
so you know what kind of independent
necroptosis is almost seems like a
contradiction in terms with that said it
certainly is possible that there are
other ways to activate ml KL the
downstream a vector of necroptosis
independent of the Rifkin is and you
know how that how that might work is it
is not clear but you know that's that
you certainly could get a program form
of death it depends on MLK l but is
independent of 3d to my knowledge that
hasn't been well described at this point
to all cells expressed with twenties no
they do not highly expressed during
embryonic development in many cell types
but many cells down regulate risk free
as adults the madoff wedeck's cells
consistently express a good amount of
risk free and as I've already mentioned
richly is interference peaceable and so
it can it can potentially be upregulated
in some cells importantly very
importantly for the study of this
pathway many of the tissue culture cells
that we routinely use laughs richly so
for example HeLa cells soon as we feed
cells HTT 1/16 cells all be sort of
standard heavily use elaborate
laboratory cell lines have law strip
three expressions and why that's the
case as it is a separate question but
you know if you just take your normal
HeLa cells and try to induce necroptosis
and them nothing will happen so there
are a couple of commonly used cell lines
in addition to madoff wedeck cell lines
like turkette cells you can also try HT
29 cells at the human cell line that
does Express free and they can be
induced under directive ptosis
but just check in the literature before
you start trying to do necroptosis
Studies on a old cell line because many
of them have lost written expression
let's see can you differentiate between
pyroptosis and Apatow sious in vivo or
in vitro how can you measure boat I
would argue that you that you can't
easily differentiate between appetizers
and pyroptosis
they're both castes dependent the
quote-unquote specific inhibitors of the
different caste bases and to not
actually be very specific at all I think
that using knockout animals or now with
the advent of CRISPR technology knocking
out specific effectors of the pathways
is really your best best bet for for for
differentiating between those two those
two firms who sell that let's see is it
known how tlr3 or for binding leads to
activation for three yeah the downstream
adapter protein Chris has a rim domain
so it has the city domain that activates
rip 130 and and so trip trip activation
can directly activate either rip 1 or
riff 3 interesting so that can be rip
one dependent or grip once independent
depending on on what's going on himself
is there any less cell that's when using
IAT
I in PDF NC a rather than XIV at FM a so
I ET DFM say is a specific inhibitor of
caspase-8 and we observe comfortable
amounts of cell that's using either of
those competitors you know we also have
done that by knocking down cafe didn't
stop so greatly sensitized that gate so
then you know that that all points to it
being a specific effects on cafes cafes
ate with that said the man can be
somewhat a specific so something to keep
in mind finally I think this is the last
question is there evidence for the
recruitment of the root 3 all tumors to
the bad complex by Rick one rather than
monomer or dimer rift 3 what is known
about the MLK L downstream targets is
fossil Emma good Victor let's see I
think so
dollarization of lip 3 the Rio lemurs
seem to be illumination does need to be
required for the potent recruitment of
of of rip 3
I'm sorry rip one and cats busy so I
think you do need to only comprise rip
free to get to get that complex to
really form downstream and they'll KL
targets are currently described as being
the membrane so ml KL can directly
translate to the membrane and and poke
holes in it essentially so that's you
know whether that I my guess is that
there are some other other factors
involved it's not just ml as a membrane
that there are probably some modulator
of MLK l activation membrane but that
has not yet been been well described
possible ml KL as I said is about as
good as we have now for MLK lapidation
so that's the best the best relations
that we've that has been developed
innate hopefully some better or
additional versions of that of those
types of reagents will be the be
developed shortly let's see a couple
final late-breaking questions here is a
relation of necroptosis signaling with
calcium if there is one I'm not I don't
think it's well described it's
well-defined necroptosis you know there
yeah I don't know I guess I would have
to I'd have to take the fifth on that
one and finally did you experience an
additive response when you stimulate
membranes with membrane receptors as
well so I guess this would be in the
context of the of the dimerization
studies when we sit when you stimulus
with membrane with membrane receptors
you get pretty limited cell death anyway
when you stimulate with membrane
receptors in combination with zeebad you
get nearly a hundred percent cell death
with either these are with with with the
membrane receptors but you also get a
hundred and cell death with any of our
activatable rip threes so the answer is
essentially there's no because in when
you induce necroptosis by either pathway
it's nearly 100 percent and so you can't
really you can't really add to that
I think if you titrated things carefully
you could probably get probably get some
kind of kind of additive effect there
but we didn't really explore that
carefully
final question any relationship between
mitochondrial dysfunction in the Rif
kinase pathway probably but it has not
really been been described terribly well
there's some indication that might often
see so the elimination of AB damaged
mitochondria might be able to might be
able to activate rip 3 in some context
but you know my work is not clear so
that's it I think that's I think I've
covered most of the questions here and I
thank you all again for your attention
and I think AB camp will give me the
opportunity and yes please please feel
free to contact me if you have any
further questions or comments or
concerns